FOR THE SUBCOMMITTEE- THE
ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE IS. SENATE BEGAN I
JUST WANT TO GET A LOGISTICS
OUT OF THE WAY AS A AS MEMBERS
TO CLEAN AS WE- ACHIEVE A
QUORUM. I DO TO CONTINUE SAID
HOME WATER WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCE THING HERE IN
THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBERS AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE
TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN
THE HEARING IN PERSON. WE ALSO
WEARING. AND PHYSICAL
DISASSEMBLING TEN BY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING. WEATHER
HERE IN THE ROOM ALREADY VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE. YOU DO NOT
HAVE A MASK WE CAN PROVIDE ONE
FOR YOU. WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESSES
WHEN ASSESSMENT TODAY. FOR THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM. WE CAN ONLY
COME TO A MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF
STAFF AND A LIMITED NUMBER OF
THE PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO WE CAN
MAINTAIN IT IS FACING. THEY'RE
ALSO STRUCTURE THINK OF THE-
PHYSICAL DISTANCING PROTOCOLS
FOR THE PUBLIC TO ENTER IN THE
CAPITAL. FOR THOSE HERE IN THE
CHAMBER. HAVE ANY PUBLIC
GALLERY WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
ON A BILL PLEASE WAIT HAND AND
I WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. BUT ASKED. NOT TOUCHED
UPON. YOU CAN EXIT GALLERY ONCE
YOU ARE DONE TESTIFYING A
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE
SURE TO OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING CAPITAL
INCLUDING LIMITING ELEVATOR
USED TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME.
FOR THOSE THAT ARE
PARTICIPATING THROUGH THE
WITNESS OF VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOMS OR THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATIONS- IN ADDITION. WE
THERE'S ARE LOCATED- HERE IN
THE CAPITAL AS WELL AS IN
CAPITAL GROUNDS AND TO- AND
THROUGHOUT. OTHER LOCATIONS.
THOSE WIN THIS IS WILL APPEAR
ON THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN
WATCH THE TESTIMONY LIVE FROM
OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING ROOM AND
ALSO ASK THEM QUESTIONS. WE'LL
ALSO BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH
THROUGH WHICH ANYONE IS CONTEST
VIA BILL. THE CALL IN NUMBER
FOR THIS HEARING. IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. TWO FOUR TWO. SIX TWO
THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN.
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW. TO BE
PLACING QUEUE BASED ON WHETHER
YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE BILL.
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE
LIMITED ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR LIFE
IMPROPER BROADCAST AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND IS AWESOME. POSSIBLY THAT
IF YOU ARE A MALE IS PROVIDING
TEST FOR OR AGAINST THE BILL
YOUR MAIN ON A LIVE LINE AND
YOU WILL NEED TO MEET YOURSELF
UNTIL YOU'RE CALLED ON SPEAKER.
IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS
WITH THE MODERATOR PHONE
SERVICE. YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE. AND I ONE SIX. THREE
ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE THREE.
AND STAFF WILL BE THERE TO
HELP. I ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT
THE ART WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THANK YOU
FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE. A QUORUM SO
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM RIGHT
NOW I'M IN THE SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FONG HERE.
ARAMBULA. BARKHANE BERMAN. CHIU
OR EARNING HIM. DALY D.
FRIEDMAN. GRAYSON KILEY. MEDINA
NAZARIAN. RIVAS. GIPSON. WHAT.
WE HAVE A QUORUM I THANK YOU MR
SECRETARY. I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK OUR SEPTIC COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF JOINING US TODAY DR
ABDULLAH. AND HIS POWER CAN AND
THIS RIVAS FILLING IN. WE HAVE
THE SAFETY MEASURES ON CONSENT
SO WILL TAKE UP THE CONSENT
FILE. WITH MOTION A SECOND- BY
MS GIBSON AND MISTER GRAYSON-
THAT WILL BE S. B. NINE OH NINE
DODD. SB NINE TWENTY ONE DOLLY
SB TWELVE NINETY ONE CENT
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE SB
FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE FIVE EURO.
S. C. R. THIRTY SEVEN GLAZER
AND S. SIXTY EIGHT HURTADO.
OKAY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO ADOPT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FONG HI. ARAMBULA. OUR
CAN. BERMAN CHIU. CUNNINGHAM
DALY. D. FRIEDMAN. GIPSON
GRAYSON. KILEY MEDINA. NAZARIAN
RIVAS. CONSENT CALENDAR DR ALL
RIGHT CONSENT CALENDARS ADOPTED
THE SENATOR JONES IN THE BACK
OF THE ROOM SO WE WILL TAKE UP
HIS BILL FILE ITEM THREE SB.
TEN TWENTY FOUR. IN A MOTOR I
GUESS THERE JOHNSON. THESE
PROCEEDINGS WELL MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND- IN RECOGNITION OF THE
MOTION AND THE SECOND I'LL BE
VERY BRIEF. SENATE BILL TEN
TWELVE OR HAVE GREAT JOURNEY
AND GOOD GOVERNANCE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH
COOPERATION BETWEEN. BOTH
HOUSES- BETWEEN THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEES OF
THE SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY.
AND CURRENT CONVERSATIONS WITH
HE- IT'S REALLY INTERESTING
SITUATE WE- BERMAN ENDING A
PROBE AND A COOPERATIVE HANDING
IT OVER TO ANOTHER PROGRAM-
LAST YEAR CARP HAS DECIDED TO
IN THE RED STICKER PROGRAM FOR
TWO TWENTY ONE. AND NO OTHER
AGENCY PUT TOGETHER A PLAN TO
REPLACE PROGRAM A BIG. IN
PRACTICE WILL BE GET BE PUT TO
AN END ON CALIFORNIA LAND SO
WORK- THANKFUL FOR PARKS-
PICKING IT UP. AND I CARRYING
ON WITH A NEW PROGRAM THAT WE
THINK WILL BE GREAT FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I HAVE A
COUPLE OF WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IF THEY CAN DAVID WOULD MIND
GIVING THEM A- MOMENT.
DISSIPATE I THANK SENATOR JAY
HAVE. A REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATIONS- A TERMITE CAL HAND ON
AMADOR- PLEASE PROCEED TO MAKE
OUT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH TERRY
MCHALE WITH ERIN READ NECESSITY
IT' REPRESENTING A CONSORTIUM
OF OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE
RECREATIONISTS. THIS BILL
CLARIFIES THE RESPONSIBILITY
AND COMMITMENT TO STEWARDSHIP.
IS ALSO KEY WITHIN THE OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE PROGRAM. AND IT
SAYS THAT WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO OVERSEE
COMPETITIVE RIDING IF WITH WITH
SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
RESPONSIBILITY. TO PRESERVE IN
MITIGATION. SENATOR JOHN TAKEN
BY ROAD TO CONTINUE AMATEUR
COMPETITIVE RIDING ON LIMITED
PUBLIC SPACES. SPECIFICALLY
THIS BILL PROTECTS THE CRITICAL
ECONOMIC PROVIDED BY
MANUFACTURERS DEALERSHIPS IN
THE ROLE. IN WHICH COMPETITION
IS ALLOWED. JUST RESPOND
EXTENDS WITH CONTROL. THE
COMPETITORS STICKER PROGRAM
THAT IDENTIFIES VEHICLES FOR
COMPETITION AND GIVES LAW
ENFORCEMENT EVENT COORDINATORS
AND LOCAL ENTITIES. AUTHORITIES
HEARING TO WRITING THIS
LEGISLATION WILL NOT EXPAND
COMPETITIVE RIDING BEYOND WHAT
IS TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
THINK IT WAS L. THE SEMINAR.
ARE YOU PRESENT TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. A PLEASE PROCEED.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DON
AMADOR AND I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
MOTORCYCLE ASSOCIATION. THREE
VISITATION THAT SANCTIONS
FAMILY ORIENTED AMATEUR
COMPETITION. CHANCE THAT
CURRENT PUBLIC. DISTRICT THIRTY
SIX PRECIADO THE COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT BY CARB STAFF MONEY
PROCESS THE STARTED IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN TO ENGAGE COMPETITION
MOTORCYCLE STAKEHOLDERS TO HELP
SUPPORT CARDS TO MINIMIZE
NUMBER NO ONE. COMPANIES
MOTORCYCLE THAT ARE BEING USED
FOR CASUAL TRAIL RIDING ON
PUBLIC LANDS. DISTRICT THIRTY
SIX APPRECIATES THE WORK THE
SENATOR SENATE STAFF HAVE DONE
ON THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION.
TO ENSURE THE CAR PLAN TO
SUNSET RIDGE DR PROGRAM. DOES
NOT ADVERSELY IMPACT MOTORCYCLE
DEALERSHIPS. SANCTIONED EVENTS.
WRITERS ALL WHILE STILL
PROVIDING IMPORTANT EMISSION
REDUCTION. THE BILL ENSURES
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT CONTINUES
TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO ACCESS
VEHICLE OWNERSHIP AND
REGISTRATION FOR COMPETITION
OFF ROAD MOTORCYCLE. THE BILL
ENSURES THAT COMPETITION OWNERS
WILL CONTINUE TO PAY USER FEES
IN SUPPORT OF RELATED LAND
MANAGEMENT AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
EFFORTS. DISTRICT THIRTY SIX
SUPPORTS IMPORTANT COMPETITION
RELATED PRACTICE PROVISIONS IN
THE BILL. AS YOU KNOW PASSAGE
OF SB TEN TWENTY FOUR IS
CRITICAL DUE TO THE SHORT TIME
FRAME IMPLEMENT THE NEW CAR
REGISTRATION. THIRTY SIX
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A YES VOTE
BY THE COMMITTEE TODAY THANK
YOU. I THINK THIS AMADOR SINCE
WE'RE OVER AT THE R. T. F.
ALREADY ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF SB TEN TWENTY FOUR AT THE-
MOTETS THE MONEY SIDE. J. NINE
BUT IS LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF- OF SB
TEN TWENTY FOUR IN THE GALLERY.
C. NINE. THE MODERATOR ARE
THERE ANY- ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT ARE IN THE QUEUE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN TWENTY FOUR.
AT THIS MOMENT WHERE SHOULD BE
KEPT SEPARATE OUT SB TEN TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND WE DO HAVE A
FEW WHEN Q. IT'LL JUST BE ONE
MOMENT FOR A FIRST. THE WORDS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND FIRST
CLOVER TO LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
ONE THAT TWO ZERO ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS MAY BE ME I ONLY
HEARD LINE NUMBER TWO- MY
NAME'S NICK HARRIS I'M THE
WESTERN STATE SENATOR FOR THE.
FOR THANK YOU. I THANK VERY
MUCH THANK THANK RYAN TO THREE
GO AHEAD. BUT. YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD YEAH MICHAEL SUMMER- IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TEN TWENTY
FOUR. THANK YOU RYAN WHITE
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
ED CHILDREN WITH THE SAN DIEGO
OPERA COALITION AND WE SUPPORT
SB TEN TWENTY FOUR. THANK YOU
RIGHT ONE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS KATIE
BOOK WHICH BACKED PRESIDENT
READING YOUR WRITERS WELL I
THINK THE CORPORATE SB TEN
TWENTY FOUR. RIGHT ONE EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ROBERT
PICKENS ALSO WITH THE READING
WRITERS IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
CAN'T AFFORD WELL. THANK YOU
RYAN TO THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT TWO ONE THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HELLO MY
NAME IS MIKE PATROL WITH THE
NORTH DELHI MOTORCYCLE
ASSOCIATION MEDICARE YOU READY
TO WRITERS AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF TEN TWENTY FOUR.
THANK YOU RIGHT WE LIVE IN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY TWO ONE ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LEVINE DIVIDE
ONE EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS A MAJOR
PRESIDENT REDDING TO WRITERS I
AM ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT TO ALL EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WOOD WILLIS IN
SALINAS RAMBLERS MOTORCYCLE
CLUB EMPLOYED BY GILROY
MOTORCYCLE CENTER BOOKING.
SUPPORTING THE BILL. THANK YOU
LINE TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. EIGHT
TWO ZERO TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
NEED TO TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHICH HELLO MY NAME'S
CANDY GOT WITH THE TIMES
BRIDGEWATER CYCLE CLUB- WE ALSO
SUPPORT SB TEN TWENTY FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. TO TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. BOB MY
NAME IS GERRY FELT SLAM THE ON
THE BORDER OCCURRED TODAY IN A
DIFFERENT THIRTY SIX WE- THE
BILL TEN TWENTY WE THINK IT TO
THE ENVIRONMENT WELL THE TRUCK
THE URGENT. A VOTER QUALITY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
RYAN TO TENTATIVELY IS GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME'S JEFF JOHNSON I'VE
BEEN RIDING FOR ABOUT FIFTEEN
YEARS I'M A MEMBER AND REYES
DISTRICT THIRTY THREE AND MAY I
SUPPORT S. B. TEN TWENTY FOUR.
THANK YOU RYAN TO NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT'S TIME TO
BRING A MUCH SIMPLER BETWEEN
THE RAMBLERS AND I SUPPORT THAT
SPEECH AND TWENTY FOUR. THANK
YOU RIGHT ONE EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE ONE EIGHT
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'D ONE
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE NINE THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'D ONE NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE GERMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JAMES
OF ARTISTS IN YOUR BEHALF
CALIFORNIA MOTORCYCLE DEALERS
ASSOCIATION WHICH SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION WILL KEEP
MOTORCYCLE DEALERS IN THAT THE-
I'M ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU LINE
TWO HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK TWO ZERO ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD HI THIS IS WILLIAM
BRADSHAW WITH VALLEY CLIMBERS
NAPA VALLEY CALIFORNIA WE ARE
FULLY SUPPORTIVE SB TEN TWENTY
FOUR. THANK YOU LINE ONE NINETY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
CARL NORTON WITH MOTION PRO. WE
ARE FULLY IN SUPPORT OF- THIS
BILL IT WOULD APPEAL TO GOOD
COMPROMISE THAT ADDRESSES THE
ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS AND
ECONOMIC NEEDS- AND ON BEHALF
OF MOTION PRO ARE FORTY FIVE
EMPLOYEES HUNDREDS OF RETAIL
STORES- AND THEIR EMPLOYEES
THAT DEPEND ON US WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU RYAN TO TWENTY. IT
WOULD KEEP HIM SUPPORTING BILL
S. B. ONE ZERO TWO FOUR. THANK
YOU AND AS A REMINDER IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS OF WIND AND THEN ZERO
ACTORS TIME. ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE. IF YOU
HAVE A COUPLE MORE IN Q.
OVERLYING TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUT I WANT NINE ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT A
LINE TO ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT TO LIVE ANYWHERE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT TRY WHAT
NINE ONE NINETY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I HAVE NO FURTHER
BINDING QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THERE NEEDS TO ARE THE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES. I HAVE NO
FURTHER LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME OKAY. OKAY THANK YOU THE
MODERATOR WILL NOW WITH YOUR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION FOR THE
BILL ARE THERE ANY IN THE
GALLERY. C. NOTICES IN
OPPOSITION. TO THE SP TEN
TWENTY FOUR IN THE GALLERY- ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO U. S. B. TEN
TWENTY FOUR AT THE REMOTE TEST
MEDICATIONS. SEEING NO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- ARE
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SP TEN TWENTY
FOUR- ON THE PHONE. MODERATOR
PLEASE PROCEED. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB TEN
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THE TIME. I HAVE NO
LINE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. I
THANK YOU MODERATOR HI WILL NOW
TAKE THIS BILL S. B. TEN TWENTY
FOUR TO THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. A MESS OKAY
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR- THANK
YOU SENATOR THE THING CARE SO I
HEARD FROM THE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT HOW THIS BILL HELPS
MITIGATE THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DAMAGE TO THESE VEHICLES DO CAN
YOU EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
HOW THIS BILL ACCOMPLISHES
MITIGATION- THE WAY I FIVE TO
ME WAYS NOW UNDER THE RED
STICKER PROGRAM IN HER CAR-
YOU'RE NOT REQUIRED TO BE A
COMPETITIVE RACER. AT TO WIRE
THAT STICKER YOUR MORE SUBTLE
SO THIS BILL BY. ACTUALLY ONE
OF THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE BILL
IS THAT ANYBODY WHO REQUIRES
THIS- STICKER FOR THEIR MORE
CYCLE HAS TO SHOW THAT THEY ARE
A MEMBER OF A- OF A LEGITIMATE
RACING ORGANIZATION. SO IT'S
THAT BRING THE MOTORCYCLES AND
THE RACERS UNDER THE
REGULATIONS OF THOSE RACING
BODIES WHICH ARE. RECOGNIZES AS
LEGITIMATE RACING-
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WITHOUT THIS- SAYS
NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO WITHOUT
THIS BILL THERE THERE WILL BE
NO PROGRAM TO REPLACE. MR
PROGRAMS TO THE- POSTED BY
THESE MORE CYCLES. LESS
REGULATION AND- LESS
REQUIREMENTS ON WHERE THEY ARE
ALLOWED TO WEAR THEM AND
WHETHER RIDE THEM AND WHERE
THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED TO WRITE
THEM. AND US C. H. P. BECAUSE
THEY WILL BE REGISTERED WILL
HAVE THE ABILITY TO ENFORCE. OF
THE PARTICULAR LAWS ON THAT
HAVE THE STICKERS. SO IF I
UNDERSTAND ME NOW SAYS THAT THE
SUGAR PROGRAM WHICH IS NOW I
THINK MORE THAN TWENTY YEARS
OLD I UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY WAS
INTENDED TO BE. TEMPORARY IN
NATURE AND THAT WE WERE
SUPPOSED TO BRING ALL HOLES
INTO THE GREEN STICKER PROGRAM
AND ALLOW THEM TO OMIT LASSEN
NEED THE EMISSIONS. UNDER THE
CARPET. THIS BILL IS I DON'T
KNOW IF I'M WRONG DOESN'T THAT
IT MAKES THE REST OF THE
PROGRAM BERMAN IS THAT RIGHT
CRAIGMILLAR WELL AS- NOT THE
RED TO. IT'S A DIFFERENT
PROGRAM. I NEED TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE VERY. CARE DEFY. BECAUSE
RIGHT THE REGISTERED APPROACH
IS MY MORE BROAD. THOSE
COMMENTS MAY BE TRUE I I'M NOT
SURE THAT IT WAS EVER INTENDED
FOR THIS. TO COMPLETELY PHASE
OUT OR NOT WHAT HAS WHAT WHAT I
DO KNOW IS CARP. WASN'T
INTERESTED IN CAN ME AND UNDER
THEIR JERSEYS. AND AVERAGE MANY.
FROM TODAY. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT SPUR AND HOW IN THIS
OF. AND OUR LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE WITH SOME REGULATE AND
I WHY ROOM INTO PART PARKS
DEPARTMENT. AND THEN MY LAST
RELATED TO GOING BACK TO MANY.
IS THAT THE FOR THAT ARE. ON
THE- STICKERS IF YOU WELL. AND
GO WE ARE CONFINED TO A BED. SO
STICKERS ARE ALLOW THE VEHICLES
TO MORE THAN. OTHER VEHICLES
RIGHT FOR THESE ARE AT THIS AND
I THINK IF WE WERE TRYING TO
MITIGATE THE EMISSION THAT THE
FOR THAT WE ARE CO SHOULD GO
INTO ACTUAL MITIGATION RATHER
GO TO THE FUN THAT ALLOWED
ADDITIONAL V. EXERC WHICH IS
THE POOL. SO WHY ARE WE PUTTING
THESE FUNDS TO DO AND IT IN
PROGRAM THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO
READ. WELL THAT IS. A QUESTION
OF. I'M NOT SURE I HAVE.
COMPLETE AFTER BUT I CAN YOU A
PAR AND IN THE- IN THE PRO WE
ARE GOING TO REQUIRE SPARK
ARRESTORS IN THE MY WHICH DOES
SOME OF THE DAMAGE. THAT THE
VEHICLES CAN CAUSE WHEN THEY'RE
RAN OFF ROADING BRUSHY AREA
THIS PARKER. ANY THE SPARKS OUT
THE EXHAUST. NOT A THEM TO GET
IN THE BRUSH AND STARTED FIRE
THAT. YOU WILL MEAN ALL A LOT
OF EMISSION MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THE FEAST THE IS A- PORTION OF
THE FEE BROKE DOWN. IF HE IS
ACTUALLY INCREASE AS WELL IT'S
BEEN ADJUSTED FOR CPI SO ISN'T
AND GIVE THE APART MORE TOOLS
FOR THAT BUT I AM HAVE TO GET
BACK TO YOU YOUR SPUR MEDICAL.
EFFORTS BECAUSE OF THE- THANK
YOU AND I DO. THE SPARK NINE
ONE THESE PARKS MY DISTRICT AND
WE HAVE DO SO FROM FIRE. NOT IN
FOR RESULT. RATHER THAN
ALLOWING THE EXERCISE THE
CONTINUES TO POLLUTE OUR
ENVIRONMENT THANK. THANK YOU-
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SENIOR CENTER JOHNS IN CLOSING
COMMENTS YES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I DO WANT TO JUST MAKE
SURE I SPECIFIC I WANT TO THANK
THE ASSEMBLY- TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE THEY DID A GREAT JOB
OF. WORKING THROUGH SOME OF
THESE ISSUES THAT WERE
DISCUSSED- TODAY- WE'VE TAKEN
SEVERAL AMENDMENTS BASED ON
THEIR INPUT. AND BELIEVE THAT
WE'VE COME UP WITH THE FINAL
PRODUCT THAT MEETS THE NEEDS OF
BOTH SIDES OF THE ISSUE AND I
URGE YOUR FIVE A DAY AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR- THANK YOU FOR.
AND ALLOW OUR OUR DUTY IS TO
COMPETE FALL STILL MEETING OUR
STATE POLITICAL SUPPORT YOUR
BILL. SIX FIVE CALL THE ROLL.
SB TEN TWENTY FOUR MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. FONG HI
FONG HI ARAMBULA ARAMBULA HI
OUR CAN THERE CAN NO. BERMAN.
BERMAN NO. CHIU. NOT VOTING
CHIU NOT VOTING. CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM HIGH. DALY DALY I.
D. DEEPLY HI FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN
NOT VOTING. GIPSON GIPSON HI.
GRAYSON GRAYSON HI KILEY. KILEY
HI MEDINA MEDINA HI THIS AREA.
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS NOT
VOTING. IN THIS AREA. NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN AYE. TEN AYE AYES TO
NOES THREE NOT VOTING ALL RIGHT
TO NUYS TO NOSE TO NOSE THREE
NOT VOTING YES I WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE BUT IF THEY'RE IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS- MOVING NOT
ACTUALLY GOING TO GO BACK TO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR I DO THAT
VOTE OVER. THAT HEARD. THE
WEBCAST I'VE LIVE STREAM
THERE'S A WE HAD A MOTION AND A
SECOND AGAIN THE MEASURES I
CONSENT. SB NINE OH NINE DODD.
SB NINE TWENTY ONE. A DOLLY SB
TWELVE NINETY ONE CENT
EDUCATION COMMITTEE SB FOURTEEN
FIFTY NINE FIVE ZERO S. C. R.
SEVEN SEVEN GLAZER AND AS THE
R. SIXTY EIGHT HER TARA- A
MISTAKE I PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ON THE CONSENT OUR MOTION TO BE
ADOPTED. PAUL HI FONG HI
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I OUR CAN.
OUR CAN I BERMAN. BERMAN HI
CHIU. CHIU HI. CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM AYE DALY. DALY I
DEEP. DEEP HI FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN HI GRAYSON. GRAYSON HI
KILEY KILEY HI MEDINA MEDINA I
KNOW THE AREA. NAZARIAN I.
RIVAS HI. FIFTEEN ZERO FIVE
FIFTEEN ZERO. WILL HOLD THAT
VOTER BENEFIT IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS I HE SENT A BELL AT THE
BACK OF THE CHAMBERS WILL NOW
TAKE UP YOUR BILL SB THIRTEEN
FIFTY ONE. THE MOTION AND A
SECOND. I CENTER PLEASE PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY YEAH
THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIRMAN
BIRDS. THIS BILL IS- S. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE IT'S AN
ECONOMIC STIMULUS BILL THERE
CREATE JOBS PUT PEOPLE TO WORK-
MY COLLEAGUES THE PANDEMIC- HAS
IMPACTED THE STATE'S ECONOMY.
AND THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
IN MANY NEGATIVE WAVES THE
COUNTRY'S ECONOMY IS CONTRACT.
AND THE STATE IS EXPERIENCING A
MAJOR DEFICIT MANY OF OUR
RESIDENTS OF COURSE OF LOS
DROPS. THIS BILL PROPOSES TO
OPERATE PROJECTS IN THE
APPROVED TWENTY TWENTY STATE
HIGHWAY OPERATIONS AND
PROTECTION PROGRAM. OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS THE SHOP BUT RAISING
THE STATE TREASURER TO SELL
BONDS THAT WOULD BE PAID BACK-
BY THE STATE'S PORTION. OF THE
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENT FEE
UNDER SB ONE. THESE ARE REVENUE
BONDS BY ACCELERATING THE SHOP
PROJECTS THROUGH THESE REVENUE
BONDS THE STATE WILL BE ABLE TO
PUT PEOPLE TO WORK AND WELL
PAYING SKILLED JOBS IN THE NEAR
NEAR TERM. AND ALSO HELP US
REACH SB ONE PERFORMANCE GOALS
IN A SHORTER PERIOD OF TIME.
LET ME TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
ALSO INFORM THE COMMITTEE ON
WHAT THE BILL DOES NOT DO. THE
BILL DOES NOT AFFECT THE LOCAL
SHARE OF SB ONE DOLLARS IN FACT
THE BILL DOES NOT PHYSICALLY ON
IMPACT ANY OTHER PROGRAM.
FUNDED UNDER SB ONE. THIS BILL
WILL NOT CONSUME THE ENTIRE
PORTION. OF THE STATE'S
ALLOCATION IN THE
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM OF CREEK PROGRAM.
HOWEVER. RATHER ONLY A SMALL
PORTION OF THE TIFF ALLOCATION
WE'LL GO TO DEBT SERVICE. FOR
EXAMPLE DEBT SERVICE ON A FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR REVENUE BY WOULD
BE THREE HUNDRED TWENTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR. FOR THE
CURRENT FISCAL YEAR THE STATE'S
THE STATE SHARE OF THE SB ONE
DOLLARS WAS APPROXIMATELY ONE
POINT ONE. BILLION DOLLARS
FURTHER AS MY WITNESS WILL
TESTIFY TODAY THE TIP IS THE
MOST STABLE SB ONE REVENUE
SOURCE IN TURN PROVIDING ENOUGH
REVENUE TO COVER DEBT SERVICE
AND CONTINUE FIGHTING ONGOING
SHOP. AND MAINTENANCE PROGRAMS.
ALSO WHAT THIS BILL DOES DO IS
ACCELERATE THE SHOP PROJECTS.
THAT WOULD BE FUNDED AND
COMPLETED. FOUR YEARS FROM NOW
TO BE COMPLETED IN TWO OR THREE
YEARS IF NOT FASTER. BY
PROVIDING THE FUNDS UNDER ORDER
THEM RATHER THAN LATER. THIS
WILL PUT PEOPLE BACK TO WORK
AND WE NEED TO ACHIEVE OUR SB
ONE PERFORMANCE GOALS AS WELL.
S. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE WILL
HELP US ACCOMPLISH HIS GOALS
I'D LIKE TO TURN OVER TO MY
WITNESSES- TO PROVIDE YOU OF.
TECNICO OF SUPPORT ABOUT THE
FUN KAREN FILLED EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF FROM THE METADATA
TRANSPORTATION IT INSTITUTE AND
PROFESSOR. WALKS FROM UCLA'S
TRANSPORTATION INSTITUTE THANK
YOU THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NO VOTE. I
THANK YOU CENTER I BELIEVE WE
HAVE YOUR TWO WAYS IS VIA PHONE
I WAS STUCK WITH IT WILL START
WITH A DOCTOR PHILBRICK A
MODERATOR PLEASE. OF HER TO
SPEAK TESTIFIED. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS DR KAREN AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
MINETA TRANSPORTATION INSTITUTE
AT TENNESSEE STATE UNIVERSITY.
INFALLIBLY THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY TRANSPORTATION
CONSORTIUM BLINDED BY THE ROAD
AND COUNTY BILITY ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. BEFORE I
BEGIN I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR BELL FOR THE KIND OF
EDUCATION TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
ON BEHALF OF THE TRANSPORTATION
AND- THE MONEY ADDRESSES THE
POTENTIAL FOR JOB CREATION IT
REHABILITATION AND MAINTENANCE
PROJECT. GENOCIDE IN THE STATE
HIGHWAY OPERATION AND
PROTECTION PROGRAM R.
XCELERATED. PROJECTS IDENTIFIED
AND ADOPTED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY SHOT HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO CREATE JOBS WHILE THE
ECONOMY IS DEPRESSED AND
UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS ARE HIGH
HIGHER THAN THEY HAVE BEEN IN
OVER A DECADE WITH
APPROXIMATELY 15% OF
CALIFORNIANS OUT OF WORK. JOB
CREATION MORE OF THE WAYS
ATTRACT NOT THE ECONOMIC. OF
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENT.
ESTIMATES FROM THE NITED
STATES DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION INDICATE THAT
APPROXIMATELY THIRTEEN THOUSAND
JOBS ARE CREATED FOR ONE
BILLION DOLLARS INVESTED. THIS
IS DEEMED A MULTIPLIER AT THE
MINUTE AND IT'S DESIGNED TO
CAPTURE DIRECT EFFECT. YEAH ALL
THE SHOPPING FREE. INDIRECT
BACK DOES THAT THE PLIGHT CHAIN
EMPLOYEE OPPORTUNITY AND
FINALLY ENDED UP BACK. JOHN
THAT ARISE WHEN EMPLOYEES SPEND
THOSE HARD EARNED. THERE ARE
MANY THAT AT THE NET BUT YOU'RE
IN BY THE COST OF LABOR. HELLO
AND LYFT WHICH DO NOT REMAIN
CONSTANT. THAT YES XCELERATED
SHOP PROGRAMS ALSO HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO SAVE TAXPAYER
DOLLARS BECAUSE MAINTENANCE
COSTS ARE OFTEN MORE EXPENSIVE
FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS
INCLUDING INCREASED
CONSTRUCTION COSTS AND
COMPETITION IN THE LABOR MARKET
WHEN THE ECONOMY IS. EIGHTY
NEEDS REPAIRED NOW A WIDE
INVESTMENT THAT WILL CREATE
JOBS WHILE POTENTIALLY SAVING
CALIFORNIA DRIVERS MONEY AT THE
DATA SUGGESTS THAT MOTORISTS
SPEND IN EXCESS OF A HUNDRED
DOLLARS AND- AN EXTRA MAKE.
TERRIBLE FIXING SUCH THINGS THE
BROKEN AXLE AND COMPROMISE
SHOCK ABSORBERS THAT RESULT IN
DRIVING ON ROADS IN THE STATE
OF DISREPAIR. THE AMERICAN
SOCIETY OF ENGINEERS GAVE OUR
STATE THROWS A LETTER GRADE AND
BE IN CALIFORNIA SURFACE
TRANSPORTATION TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN REPORT CARD. OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE THE NEED A
SUBSTANTIAL REHABILITATION AND
CALIFORNIANS ARE IN NEED OF
JOHN. MAKING AN INVESTMENT AND
A SHOVEL READY PROJECT NOW WILL
POTENTIALLY PROVIDE AN
IMMEDIATE ECONOMIC STIMULUS.
CREATING KILL JOBS QUICKLY
EIGHTEEN UNEMPLOYMENT AND
PROVIDING CALIFORNIA MOTORISTS
WHICH REHABILITATED BROWN. IN
CONCLUSION TRANSPORTATION
INVESTMENTS CAN IMPROVE
EFFICIENCY AND PRODUCTIVITY
WHILE CREATING EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AND CONTRIBUTING
TO CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. REVENUE RAISED IN THE
YEARS TO SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
FIFTY ONE WILL CREATE JOBS
WHILE IMPROVING THE MOBILITY OF
PEOPLE AND GOODS IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- I BELIEVE THE NEXT
WITNESS- THE DOCTOR WALKS IS
ALSO VIA PHONE. THE MODERATOR
PLEASE HERE YES PLEASE PROCEED
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. OKAY YOU
DID EVERYBODY GET A HANDOUT HI
I'D LIKE TO KNOW THAT WOULD DYE
CAN REFER TO IT. LEAVE SEVERAL
BASS AND EVERYONE GETS IT IF
NOT PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OKAY SO MY NAME IS
MARTIN WAX I'M A PROFESSOR
EMERITUS OF CIVIL AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ENGINEERING AND
CITY AND REGIONAL PLANNING FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
I'M THE FORMER DIRECTOR OF THE
UNIVERSE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION CENTER. I STUDY
TRANSPORTATION REVENUE AND
FINANCING CALIFORNIA FOR FIVE
DECADES. AND THAT INCLUDES
STUDIES OF THE TEXT- THE NEW
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENT FEE.
I'D LIKE TO THANK SENATOR. TO
THE KIND INVITATION TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY ON BEHALF OF THE UC
IDEAS AND THE MINETA
TRANSPORTATION INSTITUTE HOW
FIRST ADDRESS TO PROTECT
BENEFITS OF ISSUING REVENUE
BONDS. THAT WOULD ENABLE
ACCELERATING TRANSPORTATION
MAINTENANCE AND REHAB PROJECTS
INCLUDED IN THE SHOP. I'LL ALSO
COMMENT ON THE ABILITY OF THE
CHANCE TO PRODUCE SUFFICIENT
REVENUE TO REPEAT THE BOND.
THERE ARE THREE REASONS THAT
RAISING REVENUE IN THE COMING
YEARS MAYBE WORTH UNDERTAKING
RIGHT NOW. FIRST IT WOULD
ENABLE THE STATE TO ACCELERATE
SPENDING ON PROJECTS FEDERAL
READY INCLUDED A SHOP. WHAT THE
ECONOMY IS DEPRESSED AND
CONSTRUCTION COSTS ARE LIKELY
TO BE LOW BECAUSE OF A HIGH
LEVEL OF COMPETITION. AMONG THE
CURRENT. CHECK IN WELL WHAT THE
STATE TO ISSUE REVENUE BONDS
WHEN INTEREST RATES ARE
RELATIVELY LOW. AND THEY'RE
BACKED BY A C. LEVY ON EVERY
REGISTERED VEHICLE IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE ANNUAL FEE
THAT RANGES FROM TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS TO A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS. DEPENDING
ON THE VALUE OF THE VEHICLES
AND THAT VALUES INGESTED
ANNUALLY FOR INFLATION. AND
THIRD WHILE REVENUE GENERATED
BY THE CHIEF IS DIFFICULT TO
PREDICT WITH PRECISION. IN MY
OPINION IT WILL BE SUFFICIENT
TO JUSTIFY THE ISSUANCE OF THE
REVENUE BONDS AT A LEVEL THAT
CAN FINALLY MANY OF THESE
PROJECTS. DO REVENUE CAN'T BE
PREDICTED WITH CERTAINTY
BECAUSE VEHICLE PURCHASES AND
THE COMPOSITION OF THE STATE'S
FLEET OF PRIVATELY OWNED
VEHICLES WILL BE DETERMINED BY
THE DEATHS OF THE CURRENT
ECONOMIC DEPRESSION. AND THE
PACE OF RECOVERY. ANNOTATION
PATTERNS OF AUTOMOBILE
PURCHASES DURING A PERIOD OF
UNCERTAINTY. AND WHETHER THERE
WOULD BE VEHICLE PURCHASE
INCENTIVES THAT COULD BE
IMPACTED BY THIS LEGISLATURE AS
PART OF THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY
PACKAGE. THE STATE OF THE RICH
DIVERSITY BUT EVEN CONSERVATIVE
ESTIMATES OF THE TEST. EVEN IN
A SITUATION OF CERTAINTY
SUGGEST STATE AND. STREET PRIOR
TO THE- ECONOMIC DATA. WOOD
COLD WATERS PROFESSOR ASHA GROW
ALL THE MAIN ENTRANCE INSTITUTE
AT SAN JOSE STATE AND HANNAH
KING FROM UCLA I PARTICIPATED
IN THE STUDY THAT ESTIMATED
TRIP REVENUE BETWEEN TWENTY
EIGHT AND TWENTY FORTY UNDER A
RANGE OF WHAT TENDS AND
UNCONTROVERSIAL ASSUMPTIONS-
AND- ONE THE BIG FACTORS IS HOW
MANY. IN THE FLEET WILL BE
ELECTRIC VEHICLES. DEPENDS UPON
THE VALUE OF THE VEHICLE AND
ELECTRIC VEHICLES TEND TO BE
TAPPED HIGH VALUE. WE ESTIMATE
THAT ANNUAL REVENUE FROM THE
TEST WOULD INCREASE STEADILY TO
TWENTY FORTY IT WOULD BE ABOUT
A BILLION POINT FIVE BILLION
THAT HAPPENED THIS YEAR TO- TWO
AND A HALF BILLION AND REALLY-
BY TWENTY FORTY- AND OBVIOUSLY.
THE CATASTROPHIC ECONOMIC
IMPACT OF THE COLD WITH
NINETEEN- WILL AFFECT THAT SO
IN MAY WE PUBLISHED A PEER
REVIEWED UPDATE OF OUR EARLIER
PROJECTIONS IN LIGHT OF COVERT
NINETEEN. AND WE AGAIN
ESTIMATES THAT BY TWENTY THIRTY
THE END OF THE REVENUE COULD BE
BELOW BUT CLOSE TO TWO BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY. DEPENDING ON
HOW QUICKLY BOUNCED BACK. WE
ARE NOW. BEGINNING A ROUND OF.
WITH NEW THAT'S ABOUT. THE
ECONOMIC PACE OF RECOVERY.
STILL THE SUBSTANTIAL BENEFITS
TO TRAVELERS AND WORKERS OF A
STABLE INVESTMENT PROGRAM IN
HIGHWAY MAINTENANCE
REHABILITATION AND IMPROVEMENT
UNDER FAVORABLE CONTRACT PRICES
AND INTEREST RATES HAVE TO BE
BALANCED AGAINST THE RISK OF
LOWER TAX REVENUES AND WE MIGHT
HOPE FOR. BUT OUR PROJECTIONS-
THAT WERE MADE A FEW MONTHS AGO
BASED ON MANY ASSUMPTIONS ARE
BEING REVISITED AND INDICATE
THAT G. REVENUE WILL BE
SUFFICIENT TO SUPPORT THIS BOND
PROGRAM. INCLUDE I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO KNOW TO STATE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY STIMULUS MEASURE IT
COULD BE SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED.
BENEFIT FROM LOCATION V. AS-
REVENUE STREAM. COULD TO THIS
YOU ACT GOAL THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THE AVERAGE TO. TODAY I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO OTHER WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT WILL START FIRST IN
THE GALLERY OTHER ANY WITNESSES
SUPPORTED SB THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE
THE GALLERY. C. NINE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY FIFTY ONE AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY LOCATIONS. SEEING
NONE WE WILL NOW GO TO THE
PHONE. A MODERATOR ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN FIFTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THAT TIME. IT WILL
ALIGN TO THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
NUMBERS TO BECOME WITH THEIR
GRIEVANCES SEATS FOR THE
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS IN
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT AND
SUPPORT. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK FOR THE BILL FOR ALL OF
HISSUPPORT FOR TRANSPORTATION
OVER THE YEARS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE BILL THANK YOU. I THINK WE
THINK WE CAN HEAR THE BEGINNING
I. THE V. CARE TO REPEAT WHAT
YOU JUST SAID I APOLOGIZE I
THINK IT WAS A TECHNICAL GLITCH.
I TO CUT OUT. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBER MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WENT
THIS CALLING ON BEHALF OF THOSE
SEATED GENERAL. CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. I THANK YOU. Q. AND
AS A REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
WE DO HAVE ONE MORE LINE AND HE
WILL JUST BE ONE MOMENT. BOOK
ONLINE TWO THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS- JULIE
RANDALL WITH THE COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR- WE ARE NOT IT
OPPOSING THE BILL AT THIS TIME
BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO STATE
THAT- WE WANT TO MAKESURE THAT
OUR MISSION EQUIPMENT. ISN'T IT
AFTER ELIGIBLEUNDER THE- THE
MOVING WE HAVE SPOKEN WITH THE
AUTHORED OFFICE ABOUT THIS AND
WE HOPE TO CONTINUE WORKING ON
THE DAY FORWARD THANK. I THANK
YOU. ARE THERE ANY DID YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER LINE OF. I
THANK YOU MODERATOR ARE THERE
NOW WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
HERE IN THE GALLERY. C. NINE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF
SB THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE IN AT ANY
OF OUR REMOTE TESTIMONY
LOCATIONS. C. NINE WILL NOW GO
TO THE PHONE A MODERATOR ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. THIRTEEN
FIFTY ONE IN THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I DO HAVE
ONE LIMA DISCUTER PREDICTED TO
BE ONE MOMENT. I TO TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS THIS IS JULIA CAN PLAY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION THE
COMMISSION DOES NOT HAVE A
POSITION ON SB THIRTEEN FIFTY
ONE BUT THERE ARE A FEW APPS
THAT PERTAIN TO THE COMMISSION
BRIDGE PROGRAM BUT I WOULD LIKE
TO COMMENT ON. FIRST THE
COMMISSION'S ROLE IN TERMS OF
SELECTING SHOP PROJECTS FOR
REVENUE BOND FUNDING CHANGE
WITH THE MOST RECENT AMENDMENTS
MADE ON AUGUST SIXTH BECAUSE
THE COMMISSION AS WE ALREADY
FOR ALLOCATING FUNDS FOR SHOP
PROJECTS. IN THE AFTERMATH. WE
AND SHOULD HAVE AN OVER ROLE IN
THE BOND. SECOND I DO TO THE
REACHED OF THE FUNDING AND THE
RMR AND THE BILL ONE OF THE
COMMISSION PROGRAM- THE LOCAL
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM WOULD NO
LONGER BE ABLE TO FIND TRANSIT
VEHICLES AND EQUIPMENT. ZERO
MISSION BOXES- I DID WANT TO
THANK THE CENTRE BELL IN A
STAFF FOR HAVING CONVERSATIONS
AND CONTINUING TO HAVE. WHAT
CAN BACK ABOUT THIS ISSUE AND
WHAT. ADDRESS IT AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD WELL EXPECTING THE
RETIREMENT MEANT. THAT CHANGE
THE ROLE OF THE COMMISSION IN
THE BOND PROGRAM THANK YOU SO
MUCH. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO HERE I. HAVE NO FURTHER
LINE THANK YOU AT THE TIME. I
THANK MODERATOR- WILL TAKE THIS
BILL BACK TO COMMITTEE ARE ANY
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM ANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ON SB THIRTEEN FIFTY
ONE. C. NG SINGLE QUESTIONS. A
CEREBELLUM MAYBE YOU'D WANT TO
ADDRESS THE CDC'S CONCERNS AND
EITHER NOW OR IN YOUR CLOTHES.
I JUST GOT OUT AYE AYE- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS- THAT ISSUE ABOUT THE
LOW EMISSION BUSES IS- BEING
DISCUSS I'D LIKE TO. RECALL ARE
A BILL THAT I CO AUTHORED WITH
A CHAIR FRAZIER LAST YEAR THAT
SOLVE THAT PROBLEM WITH THE C.
D. C. FOR THE PROGRAM. AND I
BELIEVE YOU ALL. FOR THAT BILL
SO WE'LL BE LOOKING AT- THE
PROVISIONS OF OUR FORMER BILL.
AND SEE IF THERE ARE. NOW
WILLING TO CONSIDER THAT-
SOLUTION. AND ANY OTHERS THEY
MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU. I THANK
YOU- THING NO OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE- I
JUST WANT TO AT LEAST PROVIDE
SOME NOTES THAT IS SOMETHING OR
FRAZIER LEFT FOR MAKING GREAT
FOR THE CANNOT BE HERE WE'RE
LAST PRESENTATION FOR COMMITTEE
WHICH DOES THE THANK YOU FOR A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE LAST FEW
YEARS HAS A NUMBER FOR LIKE A
SIGN ON IT LOCAL AUTHOR TO THIS
HE WOULD ALLOW THEM TO. AS
USUAL THE TWO GEMS WILL. LEAD
THE CHARGE ON THE
TRANSPORTATION FINANCE. I WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE ADEQUATE OF
ADDITIONAL CLOSING COMMENTS AND
ABOUT OUR REGION ARE VOTE ON
THE MEMBERS. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
A MOTION AND SECOND. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. FALL
UNDER. TO LISTEN. NO NO FONG NO.
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA HI BAUER CAN.
BUT OUR CAN I BERMAN BERMAN HI
CHOOSE CHIU HI CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO. DALY DALY HI D.
DID NOT VOTING. FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN HI. GIPSON GIPSON HI
GRAYSON GRAYSON HI. KILEY KILEY
HI. I'M SORRY KILEY KNOWS HE'S
ME. THE CARDINALS MEDINA BAKER
MEDINA HIGH. THANK YOU THIS
AREA. THIS REA HI RIVAS. RIVAS
HI. THANK YOU THANK YOU. ELEVEN
YES I LIVE IN ICE THREE KNOWS
LIVING AS HE DOES I THANK YOU
CENTER BELL THANK YOU-
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE- I
THANK YOU AS AS A CLARIFICATION
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR S. C.
R. EIGHTY SIX FURTADO'S ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR NOT AS THE R.
SIXTY EIGHT AS PREVIOUSLY AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION S. R. EIGHTY.
DOT IT CONSENT OF. I THINK THAT
MIGHT THERE ARE THERE ANY ANY.
NUMBERS AND YOU'LL BE ADDED.
WHEN A PARTICULAR ON ANY OF THE
BILLS AND TO BE ADDED OR ADD
ANY OF THE ADULT. RIGHT YEAH.
ALL RIGHT I THINK WE ARE
CONCLUDED THE LETTER TO
BUSINESS BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE IS NOW
COMPLETE.